>>> This man is not Meghan Markle. No matter what
you read on the internet. He started racing online
after last Saturday's coronation of king Charles.
The duchess of Sussex had dawned a shaggy wig,
glasses and impressive fake mustache to attend
the ceremony. People tweeted, almost had me
fooled. You're not fooling us. That is not Meghan
Markle. It is sir Carl Jenkins. A Welsh composer
knighted in 2015. He joins us right now. That
seems like something Meghan Markle would say
if she was trying to confuse people and stay
in disguise. Can you confirm that was you, sir?
>> Yeah. It was I, yes. Of I was there
you have to present two photo ids.
[6:50:13 AM]
present two photo ids. In one
could have gone through that.
This spread like wildfire. Millions of
views. I think "The New York post" wrote
about it as well. What did you find out?
>> It was sudden, the next day my producer
said there is some movement here on social
media. And then I don't do social media. I
have a Facebook page. But my publisher runs that.
So, I know there is a lot of activity on tiktok
that picked up on something I did. So, yeah,
people come up and people sometimes do come up
to me in the street. But it's been ridiculous the
last week. People are buying me drinks in pubs.
[6:51:21 AM]
pubs. I wrote a piece of music. And he selected
that as one of the pieces during the ceremony. So,
that's why I was there. As a composer. They
can look up my website and see it there.
>> All my glory.
>> And I know
I met Meghan Markle and Harry twice. Once was
when I did a concert for them for his charity.
It was help the heroes, two military charities.
We performed my lasting peace. That is at Carnegie
hall. But they were there. And they were charming.
She was charming and friendly. As I said,
I met them twice. And I really hope she's not
upset by all this. It had nothing to do with me.
>> I think she has a few other things
to be upset by, not this. Wait.
[6:52:21 AM]
Wait. Just to confirm. You weren't there to steal
the crown right? Want to get it on the record.
>> No. That's another one.
That's another one that came up.
>> I do want to ask you --
>> Certainly not.
>> People need to realize is your music was played
during the coronation ceremony. You're releasing
a new single next Friday. It is part of your new
album. One which is coming out in a couple weeks.
All before you set off on major tour. Can you
just, for people who are putting together who
you are and what you've done over the course of
your career, this moment for you musically as you
launch your new album and your tour.
>>
I've been -- I left the royal academy of music in
London in the late 60s. I was in band called soft
machine. I toured the states for a bit. I was on
a couple television commercials for diamonds and
[6:53:25 AM]
commercials for diamonds and delta
airlines, both of which are popular.
And now I like what I do. I write
music. I have 3,000 performances on
my masterpiece. And the new album is one
about the planet. It looked like slavery.
Issues facing us at this time on the
planet. It's a good time to look at this.
>> Indeed. We will let you go, sir, with the
beautiful music of crossing the stone that was
played at the coronation alongside the orchestra.
Thank you. Thank you very, very much for